madame simone veil était l'invité à 20h
de patrick poivre d'arvor le ministre de
la santé a détaillé les mesures qu'elle
a proposé ce matin au conseil des
ministres pour réduire le déficit de la
sécurité sociale
ces mesures et bien diminué le
remboursement de certains médicaments
qu'elle qualifie de confort et elle
qu'elle estime non indispensables
d'autre part supprimé le ticket
modérateur pour les médicaments et
irremplaçable et coûteux qui serait
alors remboursés à 100%
enfin il propose de mettre en place une
réforme de la gestion des hôpitaux avec
l'instauration d'un forfait journalier
une somme égale pour tous quel que soit
le motif de ces jours patrick poivre
d'arvor vient demander si ces mesures
seraient suffisantes
et si le ministre de la santé pouvait
s'engager à ne pas augmenter les
cotisations en la république a pris un
engagement sur ce point bien sûr pour
l'avenir si les français ne se
disciplinent pas s'ils ne savent pas si
nous-mêmes nous ne faisons pas les
efforts de meilleure gestion
hospitalière de meilleure gestion dans
tous les domaines de contrôle du profil
médical sans doute on continuera à
augmenter de consommer davantage encore
et à ce moment là comme il faut plier un
équilibre sauf à précipiter encore
l'inflation se serait ce qui serait une
catastrophe
on sera bien obligé trouver l'argent
quelque part et je crois que c'est pour
ça que c'est si important d'arriver à
cette maîtrise des coûts pour sauver la
solution je crois qu'il faut vraiment
que les français comprennent cela ce
qu'il ne faut pas porter atteinte à la
qualité des soins ne pas porter atteinte
à leur couverture sociale et cela dépend
en fait de leur discipline à tous de
leur participation à cet effort l'heure
est monté